these eruptions are enormous and they're
regular
vast plumes of steamer dash pumped into
the skies
guatemala is used to this it has over 30
active volcanoes
but three are simultaneously erupting
it's happened before sometimes with
deadly consequences
this is volcan fuego the volcano of fire
by night you understand its name
just 30 kilometers away pacquiao is
erupting as well
molten lava flows from its crater
streaming down the sides of the volcano
shrouded in steam pacquiao's peak boils
and bursts
a fiery warning of the potential for a
huge eruption
by daybreak the authorities allowed us
to trek to the closest monitoring point
near the peak it seems far away
but it's actually very near towering
above us
the noise of the volcanoes rumbling is
frankly terrifying
is it exploding
it's erupting 30 to 40 times a minute
when it gets to 80 a minute
the local experts warn a cataclysmic
event is possible
it's possible to monitor and predict an
eruption two or three days before
depending on the number of explosions
if there is more than an average of 80
to 100 explosions per minute it's a
warning a major eruption might be
imminent
whole communities live in the shadows of
these volcanoes
the grey ash steam and cloud-filled
skies hide fuego
that looms over them in 2018
hundreds died in an eruption that spewed
billions of tons of water sand and rock
onto the towns below fuego is
threatening them again
what is these communities and there's
lots of them around here
actually on the volcano are in
incredibly vulnerable to the lava it's
flowed through here before
and obviously from the gases that can
come off a major explosion
over 180 000 people live in these
communities
on the volcano and uh
most of them simply can't afford to
leave so they'll stay many say they'd
like to
but they just simply can't afford to and
they won't leave their homes
even those who have lived here their
whole lives seemed spooked
by the increased activity
lindy salan told us how the eruptions
are rocking their homes particularly at
night
when they get bigger
it explodes like a bomb at times the
windows and doors shake from the noise
that it makes
so to a degree you're stuck she said
that her family can't afford to leave
and even worse they'd be trapped by the
lava anyway
she said they'd have to head for higher
ground
on this side there are two or three
rivers so when something like this
happens
the lava flows into the river when the
time
there is a sense here that the
communities feel abandoned
they have nowhere to run when these
towering volcanoes explode there is no
place to hide
ramsey sky news guatemala